often do you wear a suit I [ __ ] hate
wearing suits so what is this a
statement of uh is it ironic or is it
are you honoring the gods of this
particular podcast I'm honoring the gods
of this particular podcast would be a
good way to put it yes no this is this
is in in reverence of and in dedication
to you
and our newfound friendship here yes
which we are uh making uh on the podcast
you and I just met yeah everything that
we're saying here is the or the first
things that we're saying to each other
so I'm meeting you on Common Ground
dressed like well I've been actually a
one-way friend of yours for many many
years since Mad TV oh
um when did you start on mentee so that
was many I mean in 90s 97 yeah 97. so I
was a huge fan of yours and the cast was
incredible it's one of the funniest
shows ever created your whole journey
watching through that was was incredible
for Mad TV to Three Stooges to the
podcast the the 10 minute pause and then
the new podcast is incredible
um cheers my favorite role that you
played was the mountain in the Game of
Thrones what was it like working with
Dragons well the dragons are usually
tennis balls on the end of c-stands but
uh sometimes they they hang out
um I am c-stand it's like you know it's
like a little like the thing you got the
camera on here oh this is like film
lingo yeah no I understand I'm trying to
impress you with my film lingo you know
what a banana is yeah and you walk like
this oh do a banana I take it back I did
not know what a banana was yeah
yeah because it's just a food yeah
normally uh I am the Hollywood folk the
lingo and I'm uh my name is Bjorn hap
Thor bjornsson and I am seven foot four
and uh yeah so dragons don't dragons
don't scare me even though they've been
extinct for a while these scientists
right as I check out yeah I actually I'm
really into video games I don't know if
you play video games there's a there's a
Skyrim
uh video game that's part of the Elder
Scrolls series and for the longest time
there's a legend that there's dragons I
think it's starting to Daggerfall and so
I always I grew up playing those video
games and dreaming of one day meeting a
dragon in a virtual world and eventually
you did in in Skyrim so it's
dragon's represent I don't know exactly
what they represent but they represent
maybe this kind of mythical creature
that is bigger than anything humans can
comply possibly comprehend maybe because
they're so they're so they show up so
often in myth from the from the
religious stories you know of the snake
and so on The Serpent and I don't know
what that is with this breathing fire
that's kind of weird it's interesting
when I think about dragons because uh
now that you bring it up these are
people that probably wouldn't have
access to the fact that there used to be
dinosaurs right maybe they did
if they didn't they're drawing things
that look like you know a dinosaur
cousin but cool that can breathe fire
and has Wacky Wings and a spiked tail
um yeah where the heck did they come up
with that because they're clearly of
course represented in mythology all the
way back to uh
no not cave drawings well the Egyptians
probably knew what the and they could
time travel so they would have gone back
to the caves with the aliens that placed
living organisms on Earth
could time travel and they could plant
Legends into the into the collective
intelligence of the human species yeah
and perhaps they were thinking of us to
do something smart with it and we didn't
we just came up with Skyrim now we're
just what's that sorry that was very
offensive I'm sorry I don't mean offend
you with your video game I'm more of a
burger a burger time uh Donkey Kong dude
oh what is that that's an original
burger time was an arcade game that
later showed up on the in television
um uh was in television I believe it was
made by Texas Instruments horrible first
generation uh video game console and
burger time you just it's like Super
Mario you just got to stay away from the
the eggs and the pickles and stuff and
you just go eat meat and you the bun
Falls and then you go down to the in the
cheese and then the meat I'm not going
to say it's as complicated as Skyrim but
uh took me a while to finish it when I
was seven
did you play video games that was that a
part of your life a part of the source
of happiness for you at all it was it
was I played video games up until around
uh I think in 2010 I got the red ring of
death on my Xbox 360. that was it that
was it I never or whatever the Xbox was
then yeah I had I was playing uh I had
finished uh the the Grand Theft Auto
that was out and finished the Red Dead
Redemption so I was doing that thing
where you just drive around uh you know
the streets of New York or just ride
around on your horse shooting people and
uh you know throwing grenades into into
groups of people in uh Grand Theft and
you're describing the same thing that
happened a decade later because it's now
Red Dead Redemption 2 and there's still
not a new Grand Theft Auto so yeah there
isn't right yeah they're working on it
they're always flirting with that idea